here to talk about the upcoming election
and the president's rally is New York
Times opinion columnist and CBS News
political analyst Jamelle Bouie jamel
good morning I want to start with the
president's rally obviously falling on
the Juneteenth weekend originally it
should have been on Juneteenth but he
did move it especially right now can you
explain what the significance is of this
Juneteenth holiday so dream team
celebrates the arrival of news of
emancipation to insulate people in Texas
in 1865 in 1863 the Emancipation
Proclamation is issued but slave owners
in Louisiana and Mississippi go west to
Texas and it doesn't reach there and say
people until two years later and I think
the holiday in addition to celebrating
freedom also is the acknowledgement of
the distance between what is promised
and what has lived so that's the
significance I think especially in this
moment when we're seeing with big
killing of George Floyd but the larger
conversation about police brutality very
much the distance between what as
promised as far as our rights as
American citizens one has actually lived
as far as our rights as American
citizens I'll take a Jamel Joe Biden you
have said has said I'll seek to heal the
racial wounds that have long plagued our
country the question is for a lot of
people with so much going on is that
enough to say and what is the process
moving forward for him you know I think
whether it's enough to say hey we'll
depend on sort of where you are relative
to those wounds I think many Americans
many black Americans especially younger
black Americans who really are the ones
driving much of this activity in the
streets will hear this and say maybe
that's not really enough and a civics in
that Biden needs to do more you need to
say more I think it's going to involve
really doing the kind of outreach and
work with younger black Americans
younger Americans of color younger
Americans period to show them persuade
them convinced them that if elected
president his administration will take
these things seriously not just as a
matter of rhetoric but also as a matter
of policy with so many people
out on the streets Jamel you know this
president is has contended he is the
law-and-order president but you contend
and in you wrote a law and order
campaign just isn't available to trump
why you know it's it's funny
Nixon Richard Nixon who had served the
first law and order campaign could do so
because he was not in power he was the
challenger to Lyndon Johnson he has last
the last opposite he held was vice
president under Eisenhower so he could
sort of he could say in my previous
position we helped maintain the order be
helped maintain a sense of normalcy but
when you're actually in power when you
are the incumbent when presumably you
have the ability to maintain order it's
difficult I'll say to run a
law-and-order campaign when the disorder
is happening under your watch and I
think that's the president's fundamental
problem that voters will hear him say I
will be a law-and-order president and
they will reasonably say well if you
worry law and order president where is
the law and order now Tramel last night
in a TV interview the vice president
Mike Pence was asked about Juneteenth he
did speak about Juneteenth at length but
he did he was pressed on this he would
not say black lives matter what do you
make of that and what message does that
send to voters so so what I make of that
is the extent to which that phrase black
lives matter is this kind of culture war
football it's it's interesting since
majorities of Americans but I think a
significant majority of Americans agree
that there that that the black lives
matter movement on the right track on
our target that there are these problems
in policing in society be addressed but
amongst some Americans black lives
matter seems to be understood as like a
provocation as a statement of
exclusivity they add sort of a silent
only to black lives matter and I think
for vice-president pence who is of
course a member of the trauma
administration those Americans as voters
are part of the Trump coalition that
they voted to a racially resent
and so I think he's doing politics for
he does not want to say something that
may offend his voters and I think this
gets us rid of the key problem facing
President Trump going in to the election
which is that he needs to expand his
coalition beyond this base he assembled
in 2016 on the basis of the kind of
resentment against movements like black
lives matter but he and his
administration are just unwilling to do
that even doubting if things like the
low black unemployment rate prior to the
pandemic having the criminal justice
reform of his administration signed
isn't enough to make up for the fact
that we have this wide-ranging social
movement happening and the president and
his allies simply are unwilling to
acknowledge it in a positive way and are
frequently acknowledging it in a
negative way
all right Jamel thank you very much for
your time the op-ed is why Juneteenth
matters it's it's worth originally
thanks very much